seen from Earth our son is a blinding  ball of light but take away the glare  and one of the most powerful objects in  the universe appears in our own backyard  it's a ball of superheated gas that's  been lighting our solar system for 4.6  billion years and dominates all life on  Earth the Sun is 93 million miles away  and that means in actuality its immense  you could fit a million earths inside  the Sun  it's nearly a million miles in diameter  yet our Sun is tiny compared to the  really big stars out there  ADA Carinae over five million times  larger than our son  you  Beetlejuice three hundred times larger  than ADA Carinae if it was our Sun it  would reach as far out as Jupiter  and then there's this monster V Y Canis  Majoris the largest star ever discovered  a billion times bigger than our Sun